from bad to worse that's the focus of
tonight's
Angle now wouldn't it be great if we had
a real president right about now one
whom we could look to to explain what's
happening reassure us that him and his
team they're all fully engaged a
president who could be trusted not to
freeze on Cameron mid-sentence and who
with a Steely resolve would put the fear
of God in our enemies instead we have a
president who's so far gone that the
White House called a lid late this
morning the Middle East is about to blow
Hamas and Iran are undoubtedly planning
something bigger and our
president hasn't been seen publicly
since 2:48 p.m. on Saturday when he
addressed the nation for a whopping
three minutes on the attacks in
Israel now watching the Carnage and the
suffering uh you've seen some of it
already tonight it makes you feel
helpless and
enraged nothing could ever justify what
Hamas did I I called them animals
earlier that's an insult to animals the
purposeful murder of civilians including
the elderly women children desecration
of corpses parading them around all
captured for social media kidnaping
kidnappings as
well
[Music]
of course the Biden people were too busy
focused on the violent extremist Trump
supporters to see any of this coming and
the middle east region is quieter today
than it has been in two decades now
challenges remain Iran's nuclear weapons
program the tensions between Israelis
and Palestinians but the amount of time
that I have to spend on crisis and
conflict in the Middle East today
compared to any of my predecessors going
back to 9/11 is significantly reduced I
slapping himself on the back good job
brilliant but it makes sense right
because to people like Biden and blinkin
their underlings a primary threat to
democracy and peace was never anything
like Islamic Terror it was much closer
to
home this magga threat is a threat to
the brick and mortar our Democratic
institutions but it's also a threat to
the character of our nation the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy racially
motivated violent extremists as a group
are are the most dangerous uh of the
domestic violent extremist groups and
within that the white supremacists are
the most dangerous and most Le
lethal now the sad fact is Democrats all
those people are far more comfortable
dealing with despotic regimes like the
CCP than they are in dealing with
conservatives what 74 million people
across the country voted for Trump
people in their own States their own
districts in fact Schumer was in China
when Israel was attacked and even with
all of his experience Senator Schumer
managed to be shocked that a tyrant like
XI only speaks out when it benefits
him the ongoing events in Israel over
the past few days are horrific I urge
you and the Chinese people to stand with
the Israeli people and condemn these
cowardly and vicious attacks I was very
disappointed to be honest by the foreign
minist Ministry statement that showed no
sympathy or support for Israel during
these tough trouble
times duh because the democrat's view of
how the world works is a
fantasy some of our competitors have a
very different
Vision they want to upend the rules
based International order abiding by the
international um International rules uh
based order that has preserved peace and
stability for for many years our shared
commitment to a rules-based
order that includes freedom of
navigation peaceful resolution of
disputes of course as Tony should know
now there has never been there is no
rules-based International order it's a
lie to get us to believe that the world
Community would somehow come together if
we just give up a little bit of our
freedom give it up along the way none of
these people can be trusted look at how
they continue to abuse their own power
the doj homeland security the FBI
they've become so politicized so focused
on taking out Trump that they've
abandoned all sense of Duty to America
zero attention to the real threats that
we face and everything they touch by the
way backfires the Afghanistan pull out
releasing bil millions of dollars to
Iran but don't worry all that's going to
go it's going to be used for Cs and
blankets medicines I'm
sure Iran understands that $6 billion
has been unfrozen and that that puts
them in a position to spend money on
things like attacks none of that money
has been allocated or gone into Iran yet
uh they don't get access to it and it is
only for humanitarian purposes and it
would be very difficult to see that that
money would somehow give them Financial
relief look this is fible so it changes
your psychology there's not a credit
line it's set up for humanitarian
assistance they don't give Republican
activists the same benefit of the doubt
right conservative Catholic as they do
to Iran they're trustworthy by the way
it's the same dogmatic deflection on
closing of our Southern
border
151 people on the terror watch list have
crossed our Southern border what is
being done to lock down those
individuals who now are somewhere in the
United States I don't have any specific
law enforcement actions to speak to
today obviously uh we monitor threats uh
to our national security from inside and
outside the country all in real time I
don't have anything on that for you
Martha we're get we'll look into it
though we already know what the Biden
Administration has done to our economy
they've flattened it with inflation
massive spending destruction of our
energy Independence and on foreign
policy we know it's been just as much of
a nightmare the hundred billion dollar
spent by America in Ukraine yet the
summer offensive achieved exactly what
and with China the more the CCP
embarrasses Biden the more officials
that he sends there to gravel for a new
beginning with Biden by the way soon
pulling up the rear in the suck up
parade they're just laughing at us now
tragically we're stuck with these people
until 2024 and there is a lot of danger
that could befall the United States
between then and now
but one thing we should know by now is
that writing the Pentagon this pentagon
a blank check is not the right course
they're a bunch of woke radical
incompetence not our soldiers not our
troops the
leadership this is a horrific assault on
Israel that needs to be managed by them
and smartly and I have full confidence
they're going to do just that and we
should support them 100% and at the same
time we need to be very careful not to
give the Biden defense department cart
blanch to make a horrible situation even
worse because if anyone can make it
worse they can and draw us into another
nearly two decade war in the Middle East
and that's the angled hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else